[Musique]
et avec nous donc ce soir pour en parler
c'est sillery la députée la république
en marge du val d'oise bonjour madame
rédac merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
vos côtés david xavier weiss maire
adjoint et maire de levallois perret
bonsoir à vis de sa vie va espère c'est
aussi à vous d'être avec nous on entend
un que les positions se durcissent à
travers ce témoignage c'est important de
donner la parole à tout le monde et on
le fait ici sur rt france une colère
donc silencieuse peut-être pire cost ldj
les gens nous disaient ce témoin vous
avez le sentiment c'est sillery là que
le président la république en marche
d'une certaine manière à fracturer le
pays avec ce pass sanitaire puis le pass
vaccinale à présent
c'est pas le
président qui a fracturé la société
c'est malheureusement le virus auxquels
nous sommes confrontés depuis presque
deux ans qui est obligé le gouvernement
à prendre une série de décisions
très importantes
d'abord en instaurant un confinement
ensuite en instaurant un pass
sanitaire est désormais en instaurant un
pass vaccinale toutes ces décisions
elles ont été prises pour
affronter une situation sanitaire hors
norme
que personne n'avait jamais jusqu'à
présent connu et
aujourd'hui cette situation
entraîne des divisions au sein de notre
société alors david xavier weiss à
emmanuel macron qui a réagi ce matin la
dérive des antilles vague c'est
inadmissible dit il mais vous dans votre
camp valérie pécresse se dit en
substance que le président l'a un peu
cherché avec justement ses propos sur
les les non vaccinés vous rejoignez
cécile villa quand elle dit bah non
c'est tout simplement le virus c'est pas
le président de la république n'est pas
le virus si on compare par exemple et
j'ai vu l'interview du premier ministre
belge qui a lui-même dit moi je n'aurais
pas utiliser les mêmes book emmanuel
macron ne typage en r&d français quand
on est président de la république on le
lit pas déjà quand on est responsable
politique mais encore une fois il y a
divisés sur tous les sujets mais encore
plus sur la crise sanitaire les français
les uns contre les autres ils à monter
les uns contre les autres il n'a pas
fait ce c'était cet effort de
rassemblement et de pédagogie moi enfin
nous la droite auprès de valérie
pécresse on est pour la vaccination on a
été même les premiers on était force de
propositions y compris en installant des
tentes de vaccination les régions et
notamment la région de france a été la
première en la matière déployée à
l'époque les les masques qui on suit les
tentes de l de vaccinations et dépistage
pour autant on a on n'a jamais monter
les français les uns contre les autres
on a essayé de faire la pédagogie je
pense que ce qui manque aujourd'hui
notamment chez certains réduit la
république en marche je l'aimé mais pas
tous en même ali mais on a bien vu que
il ya aujourd'hui des députés qui sont
la cible et je condamne de violence et
d' attaque mais ça prouve bien que c'est
la société qui a été mise sous tension
et ce n'est pas le virus qui a mis sous
tension c'est là dessus ça a été c'était
sur le virus mais avant avant le courant
d'un virus était sur les gilet jaune et
on a bien vu cette france qui était
fracturée cette france qui a été aussi
stigmatisé par à l'époque par edouard
philippe et alors ensuite par emmanuel
macron on voit bien que depuis cinq ans
on a une france sous tension parce qu'on
a un exécutif qui est assez méprisant ou
ne dit pas encore une fois j'en ai à les
français quand on n'est pas d'accord on
essaye d'avoir un débat constructif
d'essayer de rassembler non de
stigmatisation ne montre pas du doigt
ceux qui ont pour diverses raisons peur
du vaccin et puis il ya des gens qui ont
une à une incapacité à pouvoir être
vacciné il ya des gens qui ont des
comptes dingue compatibilité médical
alors certes c'est très peu de monde
c'est peut-être un pour cent de la
population il ya des gens qui vont par
exemple des problèmes cardiaques qui ne
peuvent pas être vaccinés ni par fader
n'y pas de mots heure là justement vous
y faisait référence à quelques instants
a cessé et le qui sont agressés on va
vous montrer
la dernière agression en date en le
député de saint pierre et miquelon qui a
été pris pour cible par des les anti
pacs avec des jets de projectiles devant
son domicile à regarder
[Applaudissements]
ces six là quand on arrive à ce niveau
de violence on se dit quoi en tant
qu'élu on condamne en bloc on essaie
justement de comprendre peut-être cette
colère et le font de cette colère
des gens condamnons blocs d'autant plus
que stéphane guéro est non seulement un
collègue mais mais devenu un ami depuis
quatre ans puisque je travaille à ses
côtés au sein de la délégation outre mer
donc oui ces images m'ont profondément
choquée je les appelais dès hier soir
pour justement prendre de ses nouvelles
et savoir comment humainement il vivait
la chose mais là où en effet il avait
agi en essayant justement d'écouter
cette colère en voulant dialoguer avec
donc une manifestation anti passe et non
pas anti vague c'est je pense que tout
le monde a raison aujourd'hui de faire
la dire la différence tous les anti-pacs
ce ne sont pas des anti lax et ça a
dégénéré il a reçu des projectiles à la
figure et ça c'est tout c'est tout à
fait scandaleux
tout à l'heure le la personne que vous
interviewez avait un discours très posé
on voit bien que oui il y a les moyens
de discuter le l'adjoint au maire de
levallois perret le disait aussi dans
nos circonscriptions nous discutons avec
les élus locaux justement pour depuis le
début mettre en place le mieux pour se
faire soigner pour se faire dépister
pour faire en sorte que la vie des
français soit sur la meilleure possible
moi je pense que c'est ont travaillé
ensemble qu'on pourra affronter cette
épreuve est
pas en divisant et c'est vrai que je
suis pas une fan des petites phrases qui
blessent les gens je préfère avoir des
débats qu'ils soient apaisées et qu'on
puisse essayer de discuter trouver des
solutions communes mais aujourd'hui la
situation est telle que à mon sens on ne
peut pas aller à l'encontre passe
vaccinale pour l'ensemble de la
population à la question à le pass
vaccinale l'ultime fracturé un qu'en
pensent les français on a eu quelques
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
l'ultime fracture a été lorsque
justement on en parlait le président
insulté et déclaré non citoyens les
non-vaccinés non vaccinés qui
n'enfreignent aucune loi vu qu'il n'ya
pas d'obligation david xavier weiss si
vous étiez vous à la tête de ce pays
comment vous vous débrouillez pour
convaincre puisque c'est votre position
vous êtes en faveur du vaccin par quel
bout prendre ce problème seul en vaut
deux choses l'une soit le premier le
président de la république avait eu le
courage de dire écoutez on fait la
vaccination obligatoire et dans ces cas
là bas on nourrit on y serait tout se
passait et les récalcitrants pouvait
être poursuivi ou j'ai déjà vu une
tribune à lire dans le parisien et qui
proposait de poursuivre ceux qui
refusaient d'être vacciné pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui mais ça n'a
pas été le choix donc un moment donné si
on impose par par la loi il faut faire
de la pédagogie et on peut bien tout cas
encore une fois les français les uns
contre les autres il fallait faire ce
dont vont tout simplement
il aurait fallu faire élire aurait fallu
faire déjà bien en amont avoir une
politique vaccinale beaucoup plus
agressive on va dire ça comme ça mais
dès le début on a vu que à l'époque
olivet verront tâtonner rappelez-vous du
la dune et ma rage très lent il ya un an
sur la sur la vaccination on n'a pas
pris la mesure de ce combat contre la
montre qui était celle de 2,2 de ce
combat contre le virus c'était un combat
contre la montre on l'a pris un peu à
chaque fois avec un peu de un peu de
décalage par rapport à d'autres pays et
je pense notamment à israël qui était un
peu plus en avance que nous en matière
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve finalement
à une échéance et on va pas se mentir et
effectivement l'élection présidentielle
est une échéance qui est dans la tête de
tout le monde et qui perturbe un peu 7,7
cette course à la vaccination est donc
aujourd'hui on a deux débats qui
s'oppose la vaccination
faut-il la rendent obligatoire à mon
sens oui moi je suis je suis un
programme simple je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance en la rendant la
médecine et puis de toute façon on est
bien vu que ça que sa protégée en tout
cas ce ne se quittent ce qui le passé
par par la vaccination même si ce n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga il ya aussi
d'autres traitements tous ne sont pas
forcément aujourd'hui ni assez bien
exploité unis même favorisée par la
recherche je pense que les traitements
sont aussi une autre arme que le vaccin
qui n'ont pas forcément été un des choix
non plus du gouvernement et c'est bien
dommage on n'est pas miser sur tous les
chevaux en même temps alors on va
regarder injustement cette tribune à
laquelle vous faisiez allusion david
xavier valls 'la tribune' ce matin dans
le parisien la loi doit sanctionner ceux
qui refusent le vaccin
voilà la loi qui doit sanctionner ceux
qui refusent le vaccin et transmettent
le virus à ses l'appel d'un d'un médecin
et d'un avocat david smadja benjamin
fall où est ce qu'on va trop loin cécile
relax et c'est l'illustration clairement
de cette tribune il faut aller jusqu à
punir parce qu'on transmet le virus et
on met en danger la vie d'autrui donc la
demande nous c'est pas la position pas
pris le président de la république ce
gouvernement et cette majorité depuis le
début nous avons pris la décision
politique de responsabiliser les gens de
faire confiance à nos concitoyens
c'est pour ça que nous n'avons pas rendu
obligatoire la vaccination et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'aujourd'hui pour tenir
cette ligne politique
on ne veut pas le rendre obligatoire
parce que justement on ne veut pas
qu'ils puissent derrière y avoir des
sanctions la vie et des chars assez
difficile en ce moment pour pour tout le
monde quelles que soient les professions
mais on doit continuer à protéger nos
concitoyens et aujourd'hui on doit aussi
surtout penser à nos soignants ça va
faire deux ans qui sont sur le front ça
fait deux ans
qu'il lutte contre ce virus
et c'est vrai que d'avoir pendant 18
mois je discutais encore j'ai encore eu
les témoignages de soignants dans mon
département c'est très difficile pour
eux de supporter de voir les gens mourir
alors qu'ils sont soignants et qu'ils
sont anormalement pour le faire en sorte
qu'ils ne décèdent pas et aujourd'hui on
a une désaffection des services de
réanimation parce que les personnels ne
veulent plus être en service de
réanimation parce qu'il ne le supporte
plus donc il ya aussi ça dans le pass
maximale une responsabilité parce que on
a des hôpitaux où il y as suffisamment
normalement de personnes mais
aujourd'hui par la maladie parce qu'il
faut s'occuper des enfants parce qu'il
ya des arrêts de travail et parce qu'on
a aussi des conditions de travail
excessivement dure depuis deux ans c'est
aussi ça le pass vaccinale c'est aussi
protéger et faire en sorte que nos
soignants puissent continuer leur métier
pas dans les meilleures conditions parce
que c'est aujourd'hui impossible mais en
tout cas dans des consignes ans dans des
conditions les moins pires en tout cas
ce texte on le disait arrive au sénat
avant de north l assemblée nationale le
tout évidemment dans une ambiance
électrique regarder ces quelques tweets
d'abord celui du sénateur ps de paris
bernard jomier qui défendent est la
vaccination obligatoire il ya encore
quelques semaines
nous débutons au sénat l'examen de la
loi sur le pass vaccinale avec
l'audition d'olivier vers ans rappelons
que cette loi n'aura aucun impact sur la
vague en cours aucun l'urgence est de
réduire la circulation du virus et sur
ce point le dispositif proposé ne
changera rien j'ai déposé un amendement
en commission des lois du sénat qui
propose non seulement de renoncer au
pass vaccinale mais de supprimer
définitivement le pass sanitaire d'aviva
son embarras à droite un parce que voilà
on est en substance
globalement pour la vaccination mais la
manière d'y parvenir mais n'est pas
toujours évidente
dans votre parti non c'est pour ça
c'était effectivement une pluralité de
points de vue effectivement l'assemblée
nationale il y avait on va dire un blog
environ trois pour contrer une forme d'
abstention au sénat c'est un peu plus
uniforme et en la matière il ya quand
même un consensus on sait très bien moi
j'ai reçu d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
bernard jomier à levallois pour visiter
une école l'école buffon on voit bien
que beaucoup d'élus les élus locaux font
beaucoup d'efforts pour limiter la
propagation du virus mais qu'on dise
bien les choses au fond c'est qu'on soit
on soit honnête en la matière c'est pas
pour limiter cette vague c'est le pas de
l'accident n'a aucun impact sur 7 sur la
vague en cours tu as un wagon micro et
encore moins sur celle qui est en train
d'arriver de chypre il faut voilà il
faut pas qu'on coup qu'on a qu'on arrive
à à ce que deux débats sur il a déduit
la présidentielle et celui du de la
lutte contre ce virus s'entrechoquent
aujourd'hui on aimerait un peu la remise
d'impôt en train d'instrumentaliser le
débat et la crise sanitaire
à cause des échéances
des échéances présidentielles qui sont
dans deux mois on voit bien on maîtrise
la peur des français à travers ce à
travers ce débat et c'est un peu dommage
qu'on n'ait pas un débat plus apaisé on
a des parlementaires et vous en êtes un
exemple madame début des parlementaires
qui sont responsables dans leurs
circonscriptions qui ont un discours
posé on l'a pas toujours ressenti au
niveau de l'exécutif
alors justement meloche 78 c'est un
message qui nous est parvenu aussi sur
télégramme semble partager votre opinion
au fisc passani talent ce sont désormais
un maximale pour emmanuel macron tarte à
la crème et tous ses déplacements de
campagne justement la campagne 1 et
cette stratégie sanitaire c'est sylvie
lac c'est une erreur qui qu'il a fait
quand même emmanuel macron parce que
comme le dit david xavier weiss on
mélange un petit peu cette politique
sanitaire et la campagne présidentielle
qui arrive à grands pas enfin il ya déjà
d'ailleurs entamé largement quand on
connait tous notre président on sait
très bien que tous les mots sont pesées
donc lui de son point de vue politique
il ne commet pas d'erreurs maintenant
moi de mon point de vue de parlementaire
je peux vous avouer que ce fameux mardi
soir où j'étais dans l'hémicycle où on
en a on savait qu'on allait avoir une
deuxième nuit de débat
d'un point de vue personnel en tant que
parlementaire c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé
ces propos qui n'était pas qu'ils
n'étaient pas les bienvenus parce que
100 volontaires s'étaient pas fortuit ah
ben non et de toute manière le président
l'a encore confirmé il a il a affirmé
ces propos ce ne sont pas des propos
fortuit le président a appris une
posture politique
pour dire qu arrive à un moment ça
suffisait qu'il fallait absolument que
tous les français et je le répète
adultes majeurs réagissent face à
l'épidémie que nous essayons contenir
depuis 18 mois en limitant les
problématiques fine économique en
imitant
la perturbation des écoles en limitant
justement la perturbation des hôpitaux
donc tout ça ça pèse sur le quotidien de
tous les français donc il ya eu un gros
effort de fait depuis 18 mois donc le
président a utilisé un vocabulaire très
non pas injurieux mais très populaire
la deuxième chose pour moi il n'y a pas
eu et pour beaucoup d'entre nous il ya
pas eu d'insultés par rapport aux
citoyens il faut pas prendre
le mot citoyen au sens non il n'y a pas
de division n'y a pas des citoyens de
première catégorie de seconde catégorie
salle y en a jamais eu et j'espère qu'il
n'y en aura jamais c'était plutôt pour
au sens du civisme voilà donc qui
s'était aussi peut-être un appel un
violon peut-être alors à la citoyenneté
david xavier weiss une erreur de
campagne au contraire c'est sur ce
registre là finalement aucun nom l'on
peut qualifier le disais je pense que
c'est pleinement assumé il ne fait pas
d'erreur de 2 séparent quelqu'un qui
fait des erreurs de langage des abus de
langage s'est pas séparé donald trump
quand ils s'expriment et notamment
encore plus quand c'est dans un média
comme comme le parisien médias écrits il
sait très bien que chaque phrase chaque
mot est pesé va être repris et il l'a
fait à dessein et c'est encore plus
grave ont fait quelque part ce serait ce
serait vous souvenez quand nicolas
sarkozy avait à lui a répondu casse-toi
pauv' con dans a laissé tous des gorges
chaudes bon là c'était quand même que
c'était quelqu'un qui a agressé le
président de la république il lui a
répondu ça a laissé des choux gras
pendant pendant plusieurs semaines là
c'était une interview bien pesé avec des
mots choisis avec et finalement il a
quand même créé des citoyens
contrairement à ce qui a été dit des
citoyens de seconde zone ils osent ils
expriment très clairement il veut mettre
au ban de la société ceux qui sont les
plus récalcitrants dans ces
récalcitrants il ya encore une fois il
ya des gens qui ont des appréhensions
n'a peut-être pas fait assez pédagogique
tous ensemble collectivement je pense
que encore une fois je ne cherche pas à
diviser ni à l'arôme n'y allèrent on est
tous dans nos veines parc on est tous
face à ce virus mais il ya aussi des
gens qui ont peur de ceux de ce vaccin
et d'autres kings des contre-indications
par rapport à ce vaccin est pour vous il
n'ya aucune réponse qui est apportée
le pack vaccinale pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se faire vacciner notamment
des raisons cardiaque non pas de pas
exact finale donc c'est un peu compliqué
pour eux
parce que c'est un amendement que j'ai
porté à l'assemblée est
prévu une réponse on a enfin obtenu
justement une réponse par rapport à cela
c'est à dire que
pour le pass sanitaire donc il y avait
une attestation particulière d'un
médecin et le ministre s'est engagé à ce
que justement il puisse y avoir un qr
code parce que là monsieur vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est qu'il y avait
une partie de nos concitoyens qui ne
pouvaient pas satisfaire à l'obligation
vaccinale pour différentes raisons
médicales et normalement en tout cas
c'est pour ça que j'ai retiré leur
amendement parce que j'ai obtenu de la
part du ministre c'était mercredi soir
aux alentours de 19 heures si vous
voulez regarder la vidéo
que justement cette situation allait
être à allait être amélioré en tout cas
pour ces catégories comme vous l'avez
dit très peu nombreuses mais pour eux
c'est très important merci en tout cas à
tous les deux david xavier weiss et
sellerie avec d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl